everybody what's going on play here
welcome to stream coca yes awesome
welcome today we are twitching and a
YouTube streaming all week here from
Comic Con which actually hasn't started
it starts tomorrow that's very exciting
and today we've got a special guest my
sister pretty great she used to be a
Blair but now she's a burn the other
challenge that Brosky over here is Chad
Creek where the coins O'Malley creeper
and today we are gonna be playing
because Comic Con straight tomorrow
Marvel superheroes Lego style very very
exciting and and yeah and so I was being
you know audio is working great oh my
god and also you can't see the game
which kind of sucks so but yes well
complete for joining us and you never
know who's gonna stop by - especially
guys stopping mine a little bit later
today sorry not not more special than my
sister I start I begin that's right if
you are here at San Diego for comic-con
this one right here is in charge of our
on into another ticket so feel free to
ask questions to people if people don't
have tickets they can show up standby
line right yes we're totally good stand
by line we're gonna stand by I'll just
come by you get in there there's only
one line so whether you whatever to have
it took you have if you have a VIP
ticket if you just have a one iota to
get if you don't have to get if you just
have a ticket you made up by drawing a
crayon a Metro pass so we know exactly
you just come to the same line if you
don't have a ticket come by eight
o'clock and then it o'clock a.m. and
that's important eight o'clock a.m. all
this information is also on our website
team koco.com
slash tickets that's right Bethel hit
you with the link in the chat that's
right but so just calm and at eight
o'clock me
or my partner in crime Sara well the
lovely Sara Savage lovely that's right
we will go through the line and give
anyone that doesn't have a reservation a
numbered wristband that holds your place
in line for the rest of the day and then
we'll tell you what time to come back to
line up to then actually claim any
leftover tickets that we have also those
times change throughout the winter
because we're taking a different time
yeah the tickets hurts my heart
Oh watch it that's my sister you
bastards watch it so just to reiterate
we have a ticket what do you do
just come on down to claim your tickets
during the box office hours which are
different every day but for the most
part every day opens at 9:00 Wednesday
Thursday it closes at 3:00 when I'm not
gonna do this right now
dojo right now here's what we're gonna
do yes we're gonna look at your etk look
at hurry ticket because that information
is correct yes what I say exactly
so what we should do is if you have a
ticket box office opens at 9:00 show
always better to come earlier yeah
because we give out the first tickets
first that's right the front don't you
yeah don't you exactly and then if you
don't have a ticket or even ticket you
made yourself which by the way we do not
accept but we would like to see we would
like to see which because it would be
awesome
yeah and I'm sure a lot of you people
are great artists then I show up by 8:00
a.m. and then see if you can get a
standby wristband and then you can come
back later today and possibly claim a
ticket to come see very exciting okay
and also again go to to koco.com slash
tickets and you can find a whole bevy of
information there though I said baby
that's a real word that's a real word
pretty exciting so today we're playing
Lego Marvel superheroes because you know
comic-con starts tomorrow I got my best
I got my best death-metal shirt I got it
from the girls section at Hot Topic so
embarrassed you know Tokyo Bears I'm
ready yeah Shaq flu your sister is cute
all creepiness intended all right all
right
yes stealthy stealthy Dalek ooh is it
Dalek or day like it's Dalek she loves
Doctor Who by the way so direct all your
Dalek question exactly
shady fridge that shirt is a babe magnet
that's right if the opposite polarity of
a magnet remember a magnet can attract
or repel so there you go that's right
after all Legos it's pretty good this is
pretty good
do we want to watch this or do we want
to skip this now let's try skip it
let's try skipping oh man oh this is
part of the plot so basically I think
Doctor Doom is trying to capture the
Silver Surfer and then so we can do
something with a bunch of bad guys and
where are the heroes and we're gonna do
something ah that's a funky question for
any of you who's your favorite superhero
why is it okay flash now my favorite
superhero superhero DC or marvel
oh by the way if you want to look back
up here we have like the hook because he
just gives them to his rage yeah and
you're wearing green yeah let that sleep
very good that's right and exactly
exactly yes that's true
yours you can't see so many x-files well
Jim Rhodes was war machine that really
Iron Man oh I took over the law
okay that's fine
I gotta go I love the Hulk yeah cuz I
also have a really bad temper
oh wow you know your tempers just under
the surface mines very deep but it days
what see what judge fish once you get to
that nugget caramel exactly carrot
welcome also I love the Hulk because he
just the madder he gets the stronger he
gets he just keeps getting stronger
there's no limit he just can't seem
stronger and stronger sure right ah man
who else I think it's funny that it'd be
like you bust out of his clothes yeah
flash man 2060 I saw The Walking Dead
Season 2 and your dashboard about the
future
well you might have seen a little bit
what could have it later this week I
want to believe that I'm not gonna have
to punch you later yeah so then we're
probably gonna play that play to Eagle
Eye Eagle Eye ah I'm still going on I
also love Batman
cuz bama is just a dude yeah that's true
he's just so dudes are really rich to
use is a really rich dude but you're not
lazy
yes I'm lazy yeah and then if you want
to go like yeah I don't know how deep
you want to get into it for molecule man
I love molecules Doctor Doom amazing is
a badass and super smart took over the
powers that stole the powers the
Beyonder don't worry about it I can go I
know this is not really does anything
how funny is it that the Commish played
that thing
it's pretty funny breno 103 wonder woman
coaster all these can be fun of targets
yeah which is rare review I've got them
for our little danger den here before
before it's a decorate all right so here
we go wait oh I'm Iron Man you're the
Hulk we should switch oh no she's not
she like you're like oh yeah
press your button oh yeah would you
rather be iron man of the hall alright
bring it up we got to smash all this
stuff oh yeah
smash it up I like with my sister my
sister makes her own oh I can fly it on
I think what she makes her own noises Oh
molecular man oh there we go it's
pronounced target Terran ah yes tar
Jamie keyframe girl yes I will be ally
at at least the first bingo night this
game is really this game is pretty dope
are you great graphics is amazing that's
right these graphics are incredible you
know I'm gonna say I was you know the
botanist and his feet are like oh that's
cool yeah well they're they're made out
of Lego
I was stressed oh yeah not anymore well
you know what just wait till we have to
fight the Sandman oh no no we gotta just
try I just got it we gotta work together
dude I'm just drawing these silver
things for you and then now you smash
the that's and stuff like wow yeah yeah
the wall boom now hit Oh to grab that
key friend girl yeah that's what we use
him hit Oh hit Oh Jimmy hey key pinning
it oh oh oh nice I love it what's going
on yes
not now Kramer is that cool thanks man
the key from girl yes but the camera we
switch to and things are going wrong
that's art going there that's our
technical difficulty camera
exactly how nice Meowth Charlie where
you bite what are your hotels Mandy I
don't think I'm sleeping and I'm
sleeping the profs department here at
the theater this couch is actually a
pull-up yeah yeah it's right here
exactly oh yeah the cool thing about
these Lego games is you can make pieces
see that what you did yeah I made it
I'll hold the guys off it buy it
whatever pulsar beam break that break it
up
ray bars I know I love cranberries comes
in and starts talking to us go away
what is creeper doing oh okay we're the
same side oh dude you got to beat him up
I don't know Wow there we go it has the
the but it shows the button and you're
supposed to do it don't make me show you
my Hulk rage
keep hitting that for you yeah keep
fitting it
I'm carpets file permitting all right oh
my god you're such an old lady it's just
a different kind of nerdiness that's
true it is oh oh this hurt Otis is hurt
oh hey when you were too young to defend
yourself oh nice
killing it on it that high five you
didn't do anything
I'm not gonna high five man you should
really just hashtag got that got that
that was the best thing I've done today
that's the thing yeah it's sane man we
got to mess him up we did actually crash
the wedding yeah there was a wedding
there was a wedding in this hotel oh I
think I did something bad whoops
wait save and continue' sorry
not sure what I got to do here what am I
supposed are you fighting the arms I
fight the other guy though
they're all on my side Mary oh yeah sure
take that side whatever
that's right flow 116 brother-and-sister
combo my pants are turning red oh that's
not good did you dye your back well I
gotta get real angry
those shoes look dumb-dumb lucky shoes
that's the best thanks to Tina FPS we
love you too I don't maybe I blow this
stuff up there we go oh yeah dude oh
dude grab that thing as the Hulk you got
it hold it hold but I'm not worried
about the whole life no dude hold hold
the triangle hold the triangle Jesus
what bet oh why there we go
then you wanna yeah grab that yeah pull
it open you know Gary berated me so I'm
just trying to beat this game yes I'm
sorry about the story we wandered into
this hotel and there was a wedding going
on in the lobby which by the way if
you're having a wedding I wouldn't
recommend having it in a hotel lobby
where two idiots like my sister and I
could just wander in and hang out it
wasn't exactly the best but they were
very nice I said to the bride and groom
I like their cosplay their wedding
cosplay they laughed so at least they
were nerdy enough to understand or maybe
they were just laughing they were like
please leave our wedding in your army
yeah in my army hoodie yeah I kind of
stood out larner they're like the city
cannons debuted what exactly you're
doing
I'm not sure I she's supposed to throw
the thing throw it at the time did you
work there you guys know maybe there's
another thing that all see this one I
have two dad
throw that one up this is my favorite
game so that would not go that would I'm
not very good at it yeah well throw it
at him yeah nice well done all right
let's go whoa Jesus come on you know
what I know like he's I know he's like
making little guys to stop us but you
know it'd be way worse is that evil
villain is just like what about just
sand in our pants or like shape us
wouldn't that be way more nefarious
thank you thank you
I've got a bevy of word choices yeah you
know what use that Debbie earlier I did
you're right a sundry amount of weird
choices how about that
here we go lying around no yeah I don't
know yeah what it wouldn't hurt him
it would be like glue she's got a bunch
of Elmer's glue and throw it at him that
would say we're like maybe like how the
cat just come and pee everywhere and
then it would just clump together and
that would stop it that's a belly let
that [ __ ] only fire a name how do I can
I cut through this only flaring evil
characters cut through that a flight
yeah we just any can't we just go around
it this is work I can't oh we're gonna
need to wet this wall of sander to
weaken it this game is about my maturity
level it wet it oh we got over here on
ice
do I have to like how do we do this
what are these little Lego thing made we
have to go up this way but we've got
this way no well that's silly
superhuman senses that's you isn't you
know I'm doing a lot of judgments on the
side oh you know if we try to uh hey I
just get wet and then I run over it I'm
fired
use your pants zoom flicks how do we use
our pants maybe try Bruce Banner trying
new Bruce Banner hold hold triangle yeah
okay all right okay so let me go over
there and talk to it let's talk it over
your Ironman to blow up the silver clock
and build a water thing Oh got it got it
got it okay thank you nerd cube all
right come back over here huh there we
go blew it blew it up there we go
all right now we're gonna build
something we're gonna build a big water
thing that case you can build a giant
thing out of a clock it doesn't make any
sense okay no I just mean this gave me
so unrealistic I now what
why should I bring this over yet I think
we got to smash that think somehow
somehow here we go oh here we go
Oh got it got it okay yeah yeah sexy
Spring Break Spring Break you are like a
wet t-shirt contest like a woman that's
the first thing you think of spring
break another good way to rinse and
mid-tier zone I got plenty of those
don't worry I'll just take care of these
guys don't worry about okay I'll take
care of it so I think of us yeah yeah
don't worry I'll just take care of it so
no big deal yeah yeah just don't worry
about us I got one let's build something
I don't know I just randomly press that
foot oh did I just get killed my case
well I think I'm pretty good yeah well
you know what someone's building stuff
they don't worry about it Tony Stark's
got it dude turn back into the hall grab
grab those handles grab those Hulk
handles my god you're so bossy well
you're not hello riobamba Co Co Co Co Co
that's right tabacky conan is down on
stage rehearsing currently rehearsing
for a big show we got it looks really
funny yeah it's gonna be awesome be
great thank you I think so yeah dad yeah
and tells you what to do
get your new shlonsky will kimbos saying
TVD whoo I love it here comes Spidey
I do like how all the Lego guys just
have a little thing on their head yeah
whoa cool
thanks you shouldn't need to do that cuz
I have jets on my feet whatever Iron Man
flying reminds me Astro Boy love Astro
Boy who's that Frank Miller and Jeff
Darrow big robot death metal rainbow
shirt that's right John so you can find
this in the girls section of Hot Topic
that's where I'm getting my shirts these
days and my life advice by the way ahead
there you go all right well you know
what if you hit triangle you can switch
between characters now it's like you
know I'm saying oh that makes sense
but then ready choose that I mean it's
just the other guy you can't be me what
we have to do is what same character
press X while jumping to web swing I see
where Mike Weir director web-swing - oh
you know what wait let me well that's
kind of cool
let me plus these pieces of
oh wow
what is a little red and blue dots I
think that means we have to do something
there right if you're just joining us
this is my sister Lisa burns you can
take all your ticket related questions
for comic-con but most of them will most
of them will end with go to team
koco.com slash tickets those plenty sits
tingling oh whoa oh I see look at this
Clemence up the wall oh wait you know
suppose do something appear it's this
about very many pieces webs pull handles
oh I see
got it that's supposed to you
yeah pull it perfect
all right let's make something
oh I see some handles there we go
do I make some pretty big stuff I'm
anything any of us can make stuff how do
you make stuff you just like no no you
just go near you you hit oh wow well I
just like to say you're doing pretty
good you're doing pretty good well
here's an instruction here
oh you yell we were I tell you what to
do and then you tell me what I don't you
know I'm gonna tell you what to do it's
the basic and strategies okay so we
gotta do that to the other one to it
don't tell me on it yeah I'm some metal
so metal ooh yeah what's just kid you
throwing stuff it's tough
oh I'm so smart I'm doing just throwing
some it's tough okay you got bail
something over here you know what bossy
oh no I don't like it it's uncalled for
was it I don't know I literally Alyssa
what's this cool thing hey why don't you
stop kicking me around Jesus Christ oh
my god you keep switching between the
characters I know don't do what you just
did it 14 times everyone it like clearly
sibling here we go
don't worry about it I'll just pull this
thing and say would you I'm literally
trying to pull with them I'm trying you
just want to stay in this level for
hours that what you want to do guys if
you look sorry
[Music]
and now the cops are out leave the
window open the cops are here Susan
keeps punching me and I'm trying to help
the game for those of you with parents
out there tell your parents not to have
any siblings it's so fun
are they coming here this is chaos this
stream is ruined this is chaos did I
pull the thing wait do I have to do
something else
you got it I think I have to pull that
thing again
yes oh oh no I got to pull this thing
sometimes already gotta hit it super
fast you go one finger teching you know
all right let's go these gold things oh
this a hole again good lord you have to
don't worry about it I'll just I'll just
do everything again
why do you just smash nothing again you
have to get the handle of art first of
all a if you came up here right why
don't you want to do that
why okay I'm up here now okay now I got
to get to that thing or no you have to
do it how do i I don't know I think dude
you have to climb up the how do I do
that
I don't why do you walk over to it start
by walking over doing get his life slips
it'll tell you I'm over there why did
you get up here I switch between guys oh
I think that's what I had to do though
no no no no you need it all right you
look read the screen if only Hulk could
reach up there oh yeah try turning into
Bruce Banner okay
no Hulk it's you have o'clock okay under
the game things my sister's know it
dog dude says you're too fat for a rope
that's what my two sons gonna say too
fat for rope Oh see maybe angry true
story
we're on tour with Conan for they
legally promoted from being on
television or Duke get get close to it
okay are you close to it yeah
try getting oh just training other
buttons too late I think yeah that's
yeah that's my secret I'm always why are
you trying NX try adding X why do you
try one of the other four buttons on the
controller that just really real I was
asking for help don't worry I was
getting pounded down here because
somebody can't and keep this keep your
mind out of the gutter
okay yeah stupid real stupid we were on
to earth Conan Lele Fraser and we
decided to go skydiving and this was a
bit heavier and they were like oh it's
like a 250 pound weight limit go Scott
ever there how much you weigh I'm like
ah like 250 and they're like oh that's
right they're like until they were like
oh you know what you'll probably be okay
that's nice ladies I would say what
they're like yeah yeah cuz that's what
you want to hear your mother go
skydiving you probably be okay yeah
first of all they told me I was
basically too fat to fly they made me
get on a scale and then they were like
yeah you'll probably be fine I was like
whatever so that's why today I just
wanted us to everyone I'm a ghost I've
been a ghost for the past four or five
years I died
too fat to fly sure that's what it was
that's too fat to fly is a great bad
name see you you do have good ideas
don't let people don't tell you what
everyone says my sorry I'm not sure you
please get your mind on the game starts
I know your stories wow what are these
gold things these both things are
important I don't know I'm going up here
oh you know what I got to build some oh
yeah yeah there we go giant cannon giant
spidey cannon let's do it yeah how do we
do oh yeah hates the water I'm just
gonna pretend that this is full of cat
pee it makes me a happy cat pee deal
with it it's gonna start clumping oh
whoops
oh God I got a wild stream my streams
all over the place hashtag wild stream
yeah Hulk I think I think I get over
here do some hulking yeah but they come
from help get up here okay please I did
say please that time something building
oh damn
see these sand clumps are just super
annoying
yeah alright Hulk it out Hulk it out
wait I gotta get this guy my hand he's
stuck in my hand I punched a guy so hard
no Ike's hit it's awesome this game is
great thanks still not dead though no
he's made of sand I mean technically
he's probably immortal the guy from
wings and sideways I don't know probably
thinking about us by watching this
straining hey guy what was his name
wasn't it three names was that like
masters masters Masterson or something
I don't think it was it was like Jim
James Johnson alright
you know it's not super fair when you
can turn your hand into hand plate this
by the way how much sand is in the city
is this a beach town weird all the sand
come over here dude when I lived in New
York I didn't see any sand at all ever I
were suppose being here and all this I
don't I'm guessing with these big
buildings maybe even downtown LA hey go
to Shea lovely Thomas a church I knew is
three names it kind of does sound like
master master master say listen oh you
know what wait I gotta do I gotta do
some overhearing
I gotta do something over here damn let
me just build an IPA here you see hi you
know the Hong Kong what he turns into
the Hulk and was like he's pooping
that's how you be looks like when he
goes from a quarter to poop
Lisa Blair keeping it classy tom is
hatin steeple somebody said Thomas
Hayden synagogue what is this over here
oh no no a this is a spider
I do like howling maybe make it easy to
figure out what to do next one of my
biggest pet peeves and games is like
when you don't know what you're supposed
like on let's play this game alien
isolation which is a fun scary game but
it's also like it's like come on man
like I don't want to wander around for
like a thousand hours trying to figure
out what to do you know like I know your
lighting cues your subtle lighting cues
they're supposed to tell me where to go
but sometimes it doesn't work because
I'm stupid I should point that out
because I'm I'm a stupid I've got a
spidey sense situation happening
my god this guy just won't quit
that's Iron Man have lasers no smoke
smoke TIA
Iron Man has repulsors right I guess
repulsors no no dude you gotta you gotta
I'm inside there I can't get out yeah
you can't try harder
I can't do it better look at do you see
me in there you know what I'm right oh
yeah look you're under here I can't get
out that is kind of screwed up maybe I
need to turn into a little guy maybe we
need to do something to help you is this
a flan to camp
oh there oh nice you turned a little guy
otherwise there's Bruce Banner please
call by his real name you know what that
crap where was David Banner from the
series it's ridiculous
all the best superhero alter egos have
alliteration in Peter Parker Bruce
Banner Reed Richards many of my favorite
Reed Richards mr. fantastic Susan storm
no it's not a gunshot no it's shooting
it is that was a gunshot
exactly they're just like stop it nerd
hashtag chicken sandwich cards been
watching The Witcher 3 clueless gamer
that's right
twitch [ __ ] yes Conan is currently on
stage rehearsing today yesterday much
worse got in on Sunday yesterday we did
a little rehearsing today we did some
rehearsing then we're gonna be doing
shows every single day Wednesday
Thursday Friday and Saturday right here
for the Spreckels theater in downtown
San Diego for Comic Con we've been using
other way hashtag Conan Con so if you
want us to see something cool that's
comic book related whether you're here
in San Diego or not use hashtag Comic
Con and get our yeah who knows anything
could happen literally anything Frank
forecastle very good all he tries very
good
Frank castles The Punisher oh yeah Matt
Murdock what about that and Matt Murdock
The Punisher is a rogue man he doesn't
mean that alliteration is a three word
phrase with repeated constant sounds
that's not true
it could be it's a very specific yeah
that you're wrong and you schedule for
the stream yes every day we're gonna be
streaming live right here from the team
cocoa danger den here for a Comic Con
every day from noon to 1 on both twitch
and YouTube and we'll have special
guests all week which it's not spring
break that's right Scott Summers will
play they are all on TBS that's right
and then you can see team coca calm
that's right or oh oh Monroe all right
dog dude I'm talking about the original
guys all right like you know like the
ones Stanley created all the Stanley
characters have not all of them but a
lot of agree what is that saying dukes
of gum you can't stream on YouTube and
twitch at once you're 100% wrong cuz
we're doing it so sorry to burst your
bubble but I'm not sorry because some
bubbles need to be burst
hey so dumb obsessive guards huh so dumb
obsessing everybody
that's right see I just dream sooner hi
stream that's right well done you look
the camera at the monitor doesn't have
anything what's your favorite novel
about how hard it is to write about
Superman Wow double dip that's awesome
well done it's very meta
we met didn't you write a novel then did
he write he made a movie about writing a
novel about how hard it was to write a
comic and then there was a podcast about
the movie about it yeah that's right see
how does the people mindful smile yes
Brian J for I've had four coffees today
and one tea exactly did you saw the
Avengers movies right these are all
people okay we're explaining this so now
how this stuff works all right it's
really easy so you guys try to run
around and do stuff I think you're on
the left so my dress stretchy oh no
you're on the right sorry so do your
Captain America maybe do you want to
play I don't feel confident in my skills
to press the kidney wait I'm yeah I'm
Captain America your captain your your
your the stretchy guy oh no all right
come on we're gonna dive we're gonna
dive down here let's go let's dive down
that's died right Sanne
oh that controls the camera let me try
no he doesn't give you any instructions
go over go I don't you know don't worry
I'm I'm just here you you're skydiving
you're just hit that eye hit as many of
those things as you can so just Jesus
God why do we let's say do we have some
questions for Sona guys if you have
questions for so the Magic Mike remote
oh okay I don't know I think my favorite
part was watching what did you do addict
rabbit over here touch ticket joined for
five minutes I didn't do that up I was
going to explore the plane and I do jump
on the plane what happened jumped on the
plane how did you do this are we gonna
need to restart this level I think we
have to restart this level oh you know
I'm gonna drop out here we go then I'm
gonna come back
alright there we go alright now let's
figure out where to go what did you do
how did you do that I just I don't know
I hit pause and then unpause let me get
let me find you don't touch me don't
ever touch me let me go please so please
stop touching me I swear to god all I
said deep-seeded oh my god oh I fell
into a giant rotor here I was trying to
get you down to work look I'm a guardian
over here are your gardening way I was
trying to get soda
Captain America's shield guard me right
now why do you hate flowers
I just want the world smell better Jonah
if you can have a superpower what would
it be I think I'm the ability to fly my
things are so boring that's not boring
we live in LA where that would be
amazing because I know traffic up in the
sky no parking you just go right into
the club well they can take anybody with
you can you bring people on your what I
don't know strong to you I strike you
senator I'm not that strong at all okay
so now maybe we gonna hook up some sort
of rigging where you could like where
hard some kind of harness really got the
EVP work alright there you go you're
flying you're flying so hit the hit the
things it's like there you go yep you
played for you again Sarah yeah are you
brothers that's right Mario Brothers is
great I don't use this like these kinds
of games are really awesome they're
awesome because the graphics are great
yeah it's amazing what's gonna happen
when you hit the ground I went cuz you
don't you're not wearing a parachute oh
wow that's awesome
that's great alright walk don't worry
guys I take care of all the flowers yep
great job great job wait try turning
around smash buttons Sona uh that's a
funky ass sort of you could be anyone's
assistant who's besides Conan's whose
would it be I want to say the
president's whoo how do you think you
would do it that time I think I would
like to if I had to be an assistant for
somebody else I would like to be the
assistant president
it's fascinating politics but I'm as you
to know I'm really not very professional
that would just be a huge problem
because I think this comment it's okay
if I'm not professional right but hey
sometimes it's better to not be
professional you know I'm saying you're
putting situations where you have to
play video games on a livestream if
you're too professional this would be
boring it's that it's boring for other
exactly I'm not sure how to get out of
here oh wait soda I think let's go over
to this Oh
oh man I could you put the display in
the middle people are asking yeah I love
it
let's see here oh yeah we was there
anything that happened that wasn't in
the magic microphone that you were happy
about they by the way decorated your
apartment for the matter what you did
especially decorative moved into also
it's a condo okay sorry what's the
difference again oh there is no
difference I think the difference what
you own it though yeah it's good but
yeah I had moved in like there was
nothing really in my part but now there
is but they did but explain though how
they decorated it they put up all the
pictures that I had but they only did it
in such a way yes so can he see how yeah
one half of my living room is totally
done in the
yeah pictures only go up to like it's
amazing I love it I have no idea how to
get out of here anybody in the chat know
how to get out of this thing oh we gotta
unlock it how do we do those where's the
key
I'm not exactly sure where the key is or
how did oh you know what made me have to
smash them oh there we go got hit oh now
hit out
I love Captain America building stuff
yeah he built a little oh now I guess we
squeeze through the grates go over they
wait go to the left so to go to the left
yeah go to the great go on top of that
great on the on the left on that there
you go yep yep get out of it yeah that's
right tried it no get out that did
nothing what what that doesn't for about
what is it seems like a really weird
turn oh my god that's kind of cool I
know so no what would you do if you were
president a stirlitz asks try going back
onto the grape I feel like what I do if
you were president what would you do
that's a pretty big question it's a lot
of responsibility such a really intense
question
this is like watching three moms holiday
three moms Jesus yeah would you do
policy what is three please
so we said this is like watching three
bombs play I'm a bad mother bad mother I
forever I'm I'm trying to eat I try I
can't feel it
I don't know what to do here let's see
what it's supposed to do but don't don't
punch the teapot you're put oh he was
here yeah and too small for a teapot I
just hit the button it was dumb
apparently you could turn to a teapot so
that's good I love it
Emperor of tamra alas our remotes
rehearsed no that's all Conan is like so
smart and funny just does it on the spot
and so that's actually really great we
shoot remotes by shooting and shooting a
tuning machine a kind of documentary
style and then just get all the funny
pieces of which there are a lot so we
try and locking try and lock in from the
other side we go or go there we go try
that hi try eating some bubbly try
smashing some buttons Iran baby there
you go yeah yep oh yeah there we go you
don't smash the mother oh he oh hit up
hold up hold home oh yeah he's gonna
build some stuff hold up me holding out
he's looking around like what that's
what I you know what's going on I mean
she was holding I was holding a button
that was in this shape okay okay this
this is the old one this is the it is
the good news everybody
oh yeah what's the purpose is so creepy
that is super creepy say say hi to the
chat we're playing video games Jordan
are you playing video games are having a
chat we're having a chat yeah are you
having a chat I was playing and then dqz
Jordan what do you have a favorite
superhero controller you had an extra
person BK well no B you could only play
two player the one even if the person
that's right oh my god the chat is
blowing yeah oh my god Jordan oh my god
do it oh god I'll lean down lean down
Jordan get to the shot oh the creeper
that's right
it's we're playing games for fun this is
it's what people do they play games for
fun right it's it's it's something it's
what humans do we play we play video
games and like a joy do you want to play
enjoy thank you you know a play you sure
you don't wanna play I just don't
understand why the chat became
associated with the video game no I mean
that we're just cruise right edge room
with fans with fans how do you have foot
time Bob with fans so he's actually
how's the espresso at comic-con you know
we just got in last night and I found
one good place it was an espresso in a
cigar bar
I love it alright guys enjoy yourself
alright thanks to and thank George
master the Yeti of the office never
comes by never
I don't know was he even really here or
is that just a hologram you might still
be back in might still be back in
understand yeah he definitely was oh
there we go look at that Kant job he
can't do that that's actually he's not
he doesn't have that power I'm just I'm
sorry to be it I'm sorry it just can't
happen not not not in the Congo to that
oh my god oh my god please go to he's
gonna punch not the teapot you're the
aren't you kept your Captain America I
know but I'm just you know in support of
the team cuts oh you guys might hear my
joke yes right here my teapot joke it's
pretty go away
ready I'm a little teapot short and
stout here is my handle here is my other
hand I'm a sugar bowl thank you like
that one wow I just got a slow ahead and
then she went back to the thing the
gesture I'm asked is Jordan during
ionized water I've never actually seen
Jordan consume anything you don't drink
the kitchen really smash that up smash
that up now you hold hold hold square
okay and then put it put the thing up
there put the hold square and then put
the thing up there on the thing I think
as Captain America whole yep yep let it
go
yeah that's right I am Groot
oh did you see you got some guardians in
galaxy right I really want yeah I do
really want to see it Wow Wow
all right get up there x2 jump oh oh
there you go
you're doing good Sona Sona what are you
most excited about for this week oh
you've been to comic-con three times
that's so many times and it's it's a lot
of fun I think that I'm looking forward
to like seeing I think just there's so
much excitement and around San Diego
that's right Joey to take over you can
answer questions how much excitement San
Diego what have you been doing so far
yeah I mean Cindy was great I did some
great fish the other night was really
awesome there's a lot of what San Diego
known for besides like the zoo the zoo
SeaWorld
okay perfect taco there's a lot of
military bases in college - it's good
point
so the military it's hot military dudes
everyone down here by the way is
beautiful it's in here it's like very
very into me yeah yeah they're the kind
of people that like jog without any
clothes on so much San Diego
come from the hot come for the hot
people stay for the chafing yeah
iego Oh get up I'm gonna get up there
I'm gonna get up do I I have to go I'm
not I'm not I'm not fulfilling my I'm
not fulfilling my party person that's
right I just want to get this across
persona and then there we go nailed it
and then this there we go there we go
yeah perfect
now there's so much to do in this game I
crazy
her péter pápai Marvel or DC guys maybe
you don't know that much about that's
right son of of says he incorporates
corporate stooge what's going on why
they're lasers here maybe Captain
America's shield to deflect beam attacks
get in there Captain America oh well
that didn't work Captain America don't
just stand there
Jesus
they're deflected the beam I got a drink
that FIBA up there oh there you go and I
think so you can get through that great
isn't this point you're home
this is Mickey this is mr. fantastic
home why do we have to beat lasers to
get into it you just have like a he lock
us like like I should have a keyless
entry it's not to get into his house
this is beyond clueless diseases yes
this is exactly this is way beyond I
love it every turn fight yes I read
comic books I went back to play somebody
says he's on the couch get in here get
in here no you take this fine I think
nice code Utah she's got a go new ticket
stuff later you sit in the middle with
that Beth can you close to her laptop
I'm sorry I make you sit next to me here
you can play all right
what do I read I read a lot of stuff
Ollie trace I read I don't know man yes
was i jealous he was in bed with Joe
Manganiello coughs yeah the you weren't
there for that she did you get that do
you help block things like standing
exactly says layin
so dapper let's try that
ah yes exactly not sure
blood lock or we are not gonna play a
dota 2 as soon as we get a PC won't
replace in dota 2 so thoughts on secret
wars 2015 they better not screw it up
Kevin 8 or 11 Sona does Conan eat lunch
wink wink what does that mean oh yeah do
you want to get Conan's lunch where you
look what are you trying to say what do
you yeah wants to go get caught in resin
I don't think that lunch yeah if you
want to help soda go get cone isn't it
great yeah sure that'd be great yeah
just we can't go to like subway or did
ya get a 6-inch meatball 6-inch meatball
extra cheese we're on the fourth floor
of the Spreckels the window is open just
whip whip it up here just throw the
6-inch meatball up here it doesn't get
up here just just keep it stuff damn
teapot group vs Superman Superman
obviously roots a tree come on bro Jesus
next Lewis gamer is gonna be a few weeks
we're very excited it's gonna be a big
one I'm very very excited
that's right army is an intern Sabo I
don't know what's what are you doing
maybe I'm being a badass I know you're
always I'm gonna take that back thank
you back the high five guys we're almost
done with today's stream but we're
streaming every single day from noon to
1:00 Pacific time right here at
twitch.tv slash Team Coco and
youtube.com slash Team Coco different
special guests every day who knows who's
gonna stop by today Jordan slant skates
so deboss SE and my sister Lisa Byrne
stopped by was awesome tomorrow thing
could be very happy with who's gonna
stop by also we're doing shows down near
Conan from the Spreckels theater if
you're in San Diego you have a ticket
come by to the box office if you don't
have a ticket show up before 8:00 a.m.
and you can get on standby and still
possibly see a show go to Team Coco calm
slash tickets for more information and
if you're around town you see us say hi
if you want us to see something cool
that you're seeing at Comic Con
hashtag it with hashtag Conan con that's
what we'll be using all week
for any sweet sweet Conan related stuff
and of course if you're can't come back
to San Diego go make sure to watch the
show every day at 11 on TBS I think this
will do it for today's stream bet Brosky
juice tamale creeper so to obsession
everybody thanks ona that you join us
see you tomorrow at noon see you bye
[Music]